elle développe en fait une position qui
est celle de d'argumenter un vécu de
préjudice elle estime que elle est elle
est mise en cause injustement qu'elle
est incarcérée injustement donc dans
cette situation dans ce vécu qu'elle
développe de victime
elleattaque à ce moment-là et c'est
aussi une façon d'exercer un contrôle
sur l'ensemble des des personnes qui
l'ont misise en cause qui l'ont mise
dans cette situation là
[Musique]
Rodica negroyou une aide soignante
d'origine roumaine avec un tempérament
de feu dans son entourage les hommes
meurent
beaucoup une fois qu'elle l'a utilisé il
n'a plus d'intérêt à à exister pour elle
elle le
jette parti de rien rodicagroyou a tout
fait pour s'offrir une vie confortable
en France pour venir elle n'a pas hésité
à tuer à deux reprises c'est en tout cas
ce que dit la justice ce qui lui a valu
le surnom d'empoisonneuse de maxéille je
suis l'innocente de maxéille je suis pas
l'imposonneuse de
maxéille ces deux meurtres Rodica
negroou les a toujours niés et cela fait
30 ans qu'elle le Martelle je
continuerai jusqu'à la fin de ma vie
défendre ma mon innocence et ma liberté
ils m'ont volé la vie aujourd'hui encore
elle multiplie les recours et dénonce
une erreur judiciaire Rodica est
peut-être sur le point d'obtenir gain de
cause avec imengali nous avons retrouvé
les protagonistes de cette affaire et
analysé avec eux les conséquences et les
répercussions de ce dossier hors
norme après 12 demandes de mise en
liberté provisoire Rodica ngrouyou est
enfin libre la roumaine est assigné à
résidence le temps de l'instruction des
demain l'aide soignante reprendra ses
fonctions à l'hôpital psychiatrique de
Laxou tout commence le 17 décembre
1990 ce jour-là le téléphone sonne au
commissariat de vendœuvre dans la
banlieue de Nancy au bout du fil un
mystérieux correspondant fait une
déclaration troublante il a des doutes
sur le décès d'un certain Raymon
jacquetel l'homme un paisible retraité
de 82 ans a succombé 3 jours plus tôt à
un
infarctus selon le corbeau rayon jacel
avait amassé une somme confortable de
son vivant 750000 francs qu'il avait
converti en bon anonyme du Trésor c'est
justement cette fortune qui aurait
suscité la convoitise celle d'une femme
qui occupe désormais sa
maison les policiers sont perplexes mais
ils doivent
vérifier ils vont donc sonner chez ce
monsieur Jacquel C effectivement une
femme qui leur ouvre la
porte cette femme s'appelle madame
ngroyu Rodica épouse et
lui nous allons vérifier chez le notaire
voir dans quelles condition cette femme
peut occuper la maison et donc on
s'aperçoit que effectivement monsieur
jacquetel a vendu sa maison à cette
personne en
viager une vente qui remonte à 2 mois
seulement il n'en faut pas plus pour que
les policiers décident d'quê é sur la
mort de Raymon jacqu
tellel on le connaissait comme étant un
retraité paisible sans enfants cependant
il s'était quand même pris d'affection
pour pour un gamin de l'Assistance
publique un certain Claude dont il avait
décidé aussi de faire son
héritier seulement voilà depuis sa
rencontre avec rodikan et gryou le vieil
homme avait changé
dit-on cette dame est arrivé peut-être
au bon moment au bon moment où il avait
besoin de soin de prés
d'affection peut-être je sais pas et
donc elle est arrivée au bon moment au
bon moment pour écartter Claude quoi
qu'il en soit les liens entre Raymon
Jael et son protégé se distendent à tel
point que le retraité n'entend plus lui
léguer sa maison et puis il y a les bons
du Trésor les fameux 75000 franc ores
bons anonymes ont
disparu découvre que le jour de
l'enterrement de Raymon Jael un homme
s'est présenté au guichet de la poste
pour encaisser
l'argent malheureusement lorsqu'on lui a
demandé son identité personne est
reparti en disant je vais réfléchir je
reviendrai un homme mystérieux une femme
étrange les policiers font vite le
[Musique]
lien les policiers convoquent plusieurs
relations de rodroyou et il monent ce
qu'on appelle
un tapissage qui auquel participe
l'employé de la poste et qui reconnaî un
homme cet homme s'appelle Roger et ça
n'est autre que le compagnon de
rodicagroyou les soupçons se
précisent le procureur de Nancy ouvre
une information judiciaire en recherche
des causes de la mort et onne
l'exhumation du corps de de Ray
[Musique]
Jael l'autopsie et les analyses
médicaulégales sont Prati à
[Musique]
Strasbourg professeur Henry koudane
c'est vous qui êtes chargé d'analyser
les prélèvements effectués sur Raymond
jactel quels sont les résultats de vos
analyses d'emblé on met en évidence chez
Monsieur Jael des taux importants d'un
produit qu'on appelle le phénob barbital
que l'on utilise dans un certain nombre
de pathologie neurologique et d'un autre
produit que l'on appelle la digitaline
ou la digoxine c'est un médicament on va
dire avisé cardiaque vous étudiez le
dossier médical de Monsieur Jacques
tellel pour voir s'il y a des
prescriptions qui expliquerit la
présence de ces médicaments et qu'est-ce
que ça donne on n pas retrouvé de
prescription médical pouvant contenir
l'un ou l'autre des médicaments que je
viens de citer c'est-à-dire laadigoxine
et le phénob barbital si on les retrouve
dans le corps de Monsieur Jacques tellel
à la suite des analyses toxicologiques
effectuées après l'exhumation
c'est qu'ils ne sont pas là par
l'opération du Saint-Esprit ça c'est
certain les policiers interrogent alors
les pharmaciens de Nancy et coïncidence
il découvr que Rodica negroyou s'est
justement procuré du Pho barbital
décidément tout semble converger vers
cette femme mais qui est donc cette
Rodica
negroyou c'est une femme de 51 ans qui
est d'origine roumaine et qui est
arrivée en France 5 ans avant le le le
déesser de de Monsieur jacqu tellel avec
son fils un jeune homme de 22 ans
ensuite elle a acquis la nationalité
française en épousant un certain gérrard
et
[Musique]
lui Gérard et lui un mari décédé dans
d'étranges circonstances en
1988 2 ans avant la mort de Raymond
Jacquel décidément on meurt beaucoup
dans l'entourage de
Rodica le juge d'instruction décide
ouvrir une autre information judiciaire
pour rechercher les causes de cette mort
et s'intéresser à cet
homme retraité et veuf Gérard et lui
avaiit 68 ans il aimait bien jouer avec
les enfants on a il nous fabriquait
c'était le mger des jouets il nous
fabriquait toujours un jouet euh avec un
bout de tuyau un anentonoir il faisait
une trompette ou un lance-pierre ou une
poupée il nous faisait aussi des des
tartes à lairable belle je me souviens
de
ça ce père de trois enfants menait une
vie paisible jusqu'à ce qu'il croise la
route de Rodica des
groyou quand il a vu comme ça il dit à
sa sœ c'est une belle poulette bon ben
c'était une femme qui s'arrangeait qui
était pas mal physiquement quand même
qui avait des grands cheveux blonds et
cetera donc bon ben elle lui avait tapé
dans l'œil excusez-moi
l'expression le 7 décembre 1985 un mois
à peine après leur rencontre Rodica et
Gérard se marient dans le plus grand
[Musique]
[Rires]
secret Jean et lui vous avez assisté au
mariage de votre père absolument pas on
a été prévenu le quasiment fois que
c'était fait vous n'étiez pas invité on
nétait pas invité absolument pas
j'imagine qu'il s'installe ensemble oui
c'est ce qu'il pensait mais ça pas été
le cas puisque le jour du mariage elle
est partie avec son fils et puis mon
père je crois qu'il est parti chez sa
sœur àncille le jour-là mais même le le
jour même du mariage ils étaient plus
ensemble vous avez des contacts
réguliers avec votre père ou pas oui je
le voyais régulièrement j'habitais pas à
côté puisque j'habite en région
parisienne mais je je remontais en
Lorine pour venir le voir et à chaque
fois il y avait la présence de rodicaan
et grouyou alors qu'elle ne vivait pas
sur
place un couple qui ne partage pas le
même toit étrange d'autant que pour la
famille de Gérard et lui cette Rodica
semble s'intéresser davantage au revenu
de son mari qu'à
[Musique]
lui quand il touchait sa retraite et ben
elle venait prélever la retraite elle
lui acheté son pain et puis son vain
puis elle repartait il vivait dans la
misère en fait une fois j'étais chez lui
et j'ai voulu utiliser la la
télécommande du
téléviseur fonctionnait pas en fait la
pile était usé alors je l'ai prévenu
j'ai dit tu pourrais au moins te
racheter une pile pour pour ta
télécommande surtout que lui c'est un
fervant utilisateur de la télévision là
il m'a dit mais j'ai même pas l'argent
pour l'acheter il avait même pas 5
francs sur
[Musique]
lui Gérard vit dans la misère mais il ne
rate pas une occasion de gâter sa
femme il offre une chambre au fils de
Madame ngroyu et il offre à Madame ngrou
un manteau de vison acheté à Nancy donc
pour pour un montant de 14500
francs cette fois-cien est trop la
famille de Gérard intervient
on a essayé de lui reprendre pour
demander au fourreur s'il voulait bien
le reprendre alors lui il a dit sil est
en bon état on veut
bien ah bah oui mais elle l'avait déjà
revendu Gérard est ruiné il n'a plus
d'autre choix que d'aller vivre chez sa
belle-sœur à Livri Gargan en région
parisienne Gérard couch chez moi je lui
donn une chambre et puis passait sa
journée à me dire je suis elle m'a pris
pour un pigeon elle m'a pris pour un
pigeon j'ai pas retrouvé mon oncle parce
que bon c'était quelqu'un de rigolo
c'était quelqu'un de joyeux et je l'ai
trouvé très triste très très affaibli
c'était bizarre de le voir comme ça on
l'avait jamais vu comme
[Musique]
ça je dit écoute
décide-toi tu as pas d'autrre solution
il faut divorcer tu peux pas continuer
comme
ça la famille fait alors pression pour
que Gérard annule la donation au dernier
vivant qu'il a signé en faveur de Rodica
un acte par lequel il lui lèue
tout après 3 mois en région parisienne
Gérard et lui retourne dans sa maison à
Custine il suit les conseils de sa
famille demande le
divorce et annule toutes les
dispositions en faveur de sa femme
merodica revient et cette fois-ci elle
s'installe chez
lui elle va se maintenir maintenant dans
les lieux va faire un effort pour rester
et dans le but d'atteindre les délais
d'acquisition de la naté
française un délai de 2 ans durant
lequel le couple
cohabite Gérard et lui retomb fatalement
sous l'emprise de
Rodica
mon oncle était quelqu'un de
d'influençable c'était pas quelqu'un qui
qui était calculateur et cetera il
travaillait comme tout le monde et puis
mais il il était pas bien
méchant retour à la case départ Gérard
annule la demande de divorce refait sa
donation au bénéfice de sa
femme alors même que dans la maison
l'ambiance est
invivable il avait peur d'elle
s'attendait à un mauvais coup d'un jour
à l'autre et en fait il vivait il vivait
dans la crainte il allait se coucher il
fermait ses portes à clés il avait très
peur
d'elle Rodica est naturalisé en janvier
88 la famille de Gérard n'a plus de
nouvelles jusqu'au 16
février sa sœur Francine reçoit un coup
de fil à son
travail j'étais au lycée
et le directeur m'appelle il m'a dit
Madame deriaac allez vite vous habiller
il faut que vous partiez tout de suite à
Nancy il arrivit un un accident à votre
frère qu'est-ce qui peut lui avoir
arrivé ben il me dit il est décédé ça a
été l'étonnement
évidemment incroyable et puis bon bah on
a filé à Custine
[Musique]
hein en arrivant à la maison chez mon
père
Rodica était là très froide comme
d'habitude aucune émotion on n'urait
jamais cru que c'était son mari qui
était
décédé surtout après un mariage aussi
aussi proche il devait s'aimer les
amoureux donc elle aurait dû être un peu
touchée quand même la première chose
qu'elle nous a montré c'était la table
de salon avec un étalage de bouteilles
des bouteilles vides des bouteilles
d'alcool des bouteilles d'alcool mais
c'était des bouteilles que je
connaissais c'était des bouteilles qui
étaient rangé sous l'évier depuis depuis
très longtemps donc elle a sorti tout ça
pour c'était son scénario en fait pour
montrer que mon père était alcoolique
que mon père buvait beaucoup et que là
il a bah il a passé sa nuit à boire et
c'est pour ça qu'il est mort regardez-le
voilà c'est ça donc c'est l'alcool qui
l'a tué c'est ce qu'elle vous dit pour
elle pour elle ouais pas pour moi je
sais très bien que mon père ne buvait
pas pour vous dès ce moment la mort de
votre père est suspect suspect oui et on
n' pas voulu entamer une démarche style
demande d'autopsie et toutes ces chosesl
puisquon avait aucune preuve Gérard el
lui est donc mort 3 semaines seulement
après que Rodica negroyou estquit la
nationalité
française quant à Raymon jactel 2 mois
se sont écoulé entre la vente de sa
maison enviagé et son décès un
calendrier pour le moins troublant et si
Gérard avait lui aussi été
empoisonné le juge d'instruction décide
de faire exhumer son corps pour en avoir
le cœur
net professeur Henry koudane vous êtes à
nouveau chargé de ces analyses comment
procédez-vous alors pour monsieur lui la
procédure dans l'instruction on va
dire des recherches des causes de la
mort est identique a une autopsie qui
est pratiquée après l'exhument
on a envoyé au laboratoire à Strasbourg
chez mon collègue le professeur Mangin
tous les prélèvements et là résultat
mise en évidence de digoxine
c'est-à-dire de digitaline pour faire
simple à un taux élevé conclusion mort
là aussi suspecte est-ce que vous avez
relevé une présence de phénob barbital
alors pas de phénobarbital chez
monsieuri est-ce que les quantités
ingérées par l'un et l'autre nous
apprennent quelque chose oui parce que
ce sont des quantités importantes sont
des taux élevés retrouvé dans plusieurs
organes ce qui est confirmé par
l'analyse des cheveux donc pas à dos
thérapeutique la réponse est non c'est
au-dessus des doses
thérapeutiques les résultats des
expertises sont
claires vu la dose de médicament dans
les deux
cas il s'agit d'un
empoisonnement Jean et lui d'après
l'étude toxicologique votre père a été
empoisonné oui comment vous réagissez
quand vous apprenez ça au départ sous la
colère un peu c'est elle en a eu tout le
bénéfice la nationalité française la
donation au derniers vivants et la
pension de
reversion tout était gagné il y avait
plus qu' de la personne gênante c'est
tout c'est peut-être cru mais c'est
comme ça que je le
ressens voilà un an et demi que
l'instruction est ouverte et Rodica
negroyou n'a toujours pas été
entendue avec ses analyses le juge a
désormais du
solide le 9 juin 1992
rodicagroyou est placé en garde à
vue
[Musique]
rodicaangroyou ce 9 juin
1992 vous êtes interpellé vous vous y
attendiez euh absolument pas les
policiers vous soupçonnent de deux
empoisonnements c'est grave comment
est-ce que vous
réagissez bien sûr que j'étais j'ai
répondu avec la sincérité que j'ai
j'étais combatti j'ai dit non j'ai dit
c'est faux j'ai dit je n'ai rien j'ai
rien fait de mal vous êtes innocente
absolument je suis innocente j'ai rien
fait de mal à qui ce soit même pas au
mouche absolument pas rien de
tout la veuve compe sur ses
positions son mari Gérard est mort parce
qu'il buvait
beaucoup quand mon jacel il a succombé à
un
infarctus on peut la mettre devant le
fait accompli elle va le nier c'est
c'est un principe chez
elle que répondez-vous au policiers qui
vous soupçonne de la mort de Gérard et
lui votre mari je n'avais pas intérêt je
n'avais pas intérêt parce que moi Gérard
était elle était pauvre donc je n'avais
pas pris un homme euh riche j'a je me
suis mariée par amour avec une personne
qui était pauvre qui était très bien
donc j'ai rien gagné j'ai rien gagné et
vous vous l'aimiez si je l'aimis ah oui
j'ta bah oui c'était c'était tout
c'était un bijou d'homme et concernant
la mort de Raymond jacquetel alors son
décès il est dû à sa maladie et
hypertension artérielle à l'issu de
votre garde à vue vous êtes finalement
mise en examen pour homicide volontaire
et placé en détention provisoire
vous allez donc en prison euh
oui j'étais j'étais mise en prison je
savais que j'ai rien fait de mal j'ai d
bien sûr que que j'ai je n'ai pas pu
accepter assez la prison je pas pu
accepter le fait qu'elle me me traite
des
impuse l'enquête
continue les policiers vont
perquisitionner le domicile de Rodica à
maxéille en Bonlieu de
Nancy nous trouvons à l'intérieur de la
maison
une multitude un amoncellement d'objets
de choses de meubles d'objets de
collection enfin des des des vases galet
des choses comme
ça c'est des vases galet donc vraiment
de la région de Nancy elle dit que ça
lui appartient c'est à elle qu'elle l'a
ramené de
Roumanie on y croit peu hein en fait on
s perçoit que ces objets là proviennent
de chez Monsieur Jacques
[Musique]
tell matre Gérard Michel vous avez
assisté à la perquisition qu'est-ce
qu'on a trouvé alors écoutez can gryou
il y a une chose extraordinaire elle
habite rue de la Justice ce qui ne
s'invente pas et on va percissionner
chez elle en présence de avocat ce qui
est normal et on va découvrir un tas
d'objets mais qui n'ont rien à faire
chez elle une tour effffel des cadres
représentant monsieur jacquesetel jeune
des souvenirs la guerre de 1914 toutes
des choses bien entendu qu'elle a pas pu
ramener de rouanie et on va l'interroger
ensuite en disant madame ça vous l'avez
pris chez Monsieur jacquetel et à la
place de dire
comme il m'a fait son héritière je
pensais que j'avais le droit en rité é
héritière que de la maison et pas de ce
qu'il y avait dedans et donner
l'impression d'être de bonne foi ou
encore une fois avouer à la place de ça
elle va nier l'évidence qui est terrible
en matière
judiciaire Rodica negroyou le crie haut
et fort elle n'a rien à se reprocher
mais un mois plus tard une lettre vient
donner une nouvelle dimension à
l'affaire ce courrier à tion du juge
d'instruction arrive d'Israël il y est
question d'un certain Herman
[Musique]
Goldstein un homme que Rodica avait
épousé en Roumanie un homme décédé d'une
crise cardiaque en
1982 à l'âge de 51
ans sa sœur Esther qui n'a jamais porté
Rodica dans son cœur considère
aujourd'hui qu'il a été empoisonné
auodikgroyou cette lettre qui arrive
d'Israël et dans laquelle votre ancienne
belle sœur vous accuse d'avoir tué
Herman Goldstein votre premier époux
comment vous en entendez parler à la tlé
que j'attendis j'ai dit mon dieu j'ai
dit qu'est-ce qui se passe je n'arrive
pas à croire la sur de mon de mon mari
qui est une personne très méchante et
jalouse que on n pas été en Israël avec
elle mais alors pourquoi elle vous
accuserait
pu'us des prétextes c'était la la
vengeance c'est la vengeance c'est
toutve et qu'un preuve c'était c'était
Herman il était
décédé il avait infarct
myocardiqueomatose bon cétait un gros
fumeur et la mort l'avait pris à cause
de sa maladie mais pour la justice à ce
moment-là un trè homme qui meurt autour
de vous dans des circonstances étranges
ça fait
beaucoup c'est pas autour de moi c'était
autour de leur vie de leur maladie
maître Gérard Michel cette lettre c'est
un coup dur pour votre cliente sur le
plan psychologique c'est catastrophique
et c'est pas de chance parce qu'on va
dire ah son premier mari aussi est mort
c'est un monsieur de certain âge il est
mort de maladie mais il a été incinéré
quand on remonte le temps on a
l'impression qu'il y a trois morts il y
a trois décès différent mais çaura un
effet catastrophique ça donne
l'impression que c'est une tueuse en
série et surtout
pour l'opinion publique ça devient il y
a pas de fumée sans
feu le juge d'instruction ouvre une
troisième information judiciaire pour
rechercher les causes de la
mort Rodica negroyou est maintenant
inculpé pour deux empoisonnements et un
homicide
volontaire mais pourquoi aurait-elle
empoisonner tous ces hommes par app du
gain par
vengeance pour tenter de comprendre les
policiers se penchent sur la vie de
cette femme
elle est née en 1939 dans un village
isolé reculée de la Roumanie elle
grandit aussi dans une famille modeste
c'est une jeunesse pauvre dans un pays
pauvre une jeunesse dans un pays qui a
été ruiné par la guerre dans un pays
écrasé par un régime communiste il faut
avoir un mémoire que nous sommes en
plein air tesku où le moindre objet est
extrêmement difficile à trouver où on
peut pas faire les études facilement et
quand on ne fait pas partie du système
du régime c'est très difficile de
vivre en
1967 Rodica épouse Herman
Goldstein un garçon nît un an plus tard
et le couple s'installe dans la maison
de la belle famille les rapports sont
tendus la vie de Rodica bascule en
1982 Herman meurt en 1982 et Rodica
reprend ses études et elle devient
infirmière dans un hôpital p
en
1985 Rodica negroyou arrive à Nancy avec
son fils un visa touristique et quelques
valises pour gagner sa vie elle
travaille comme aide
soignante docteur Francis Boel c'est
vous qui avez expertisé Rodica negroyou
alors qu'elle était en prison quels sont
les traits de caractère qui se gage de
sa personnalité quand je la vois
effectivement en prison je suis en
présence d'une d'une femme je dirais pas
dans la manipulation mais en tout cas
développant un comportement et un
discours qui bien entendu est dans la et
dans la dénégation formelle est-ce que
vous avez le sentiment que c'est
quelqu'un qui a une revanche à prendre
sur la vie oui absolument absolument il
s'agit d'une femme qui pourrait très
certainement être prête à beaucoup et
pas seulement pour elle pas seulement
pour elle mais aussi pour son fils
comment qualifieriez-vous son rapport
avec les hommes alors je pense que les
les les relations et les rapports
qu'elle peut avoir avec le l'agent
masculine ne sont pas des rapports
inscrits dans le dans la dans le
registre ou dans la dynamique de la
séduction je pense que c'est c'est tout
à fait d'un autre registre lorsqu'elle
est en présence d'un homme est-ce que
cet homme est intéressant pour moi de
telle façon que je puisse l'utiliser et
une fois qu'elle l'a utiliser il n'a
plus d'intérêt à à exister pour elle
elle le jette comme elle jetterait un
objet pendant ce temps en prison Rodica
ne se laisse pas abattre elle est
innocente et elle compte bien le
démontrer son avocat demande une
contre-expertise toxicchologique maître
Gérard Michel qui est désigné pour
procéder à cette contre-expertise alors
cette contreexpertise elle va être
confiée au plus grand expert français de
l'époque madame Rudler qui dirige le
laboratoire de la préfecture de police
qui est expert près la Cour de cassation
qui est une autorité incontestée quels
sont les résultats qu'est-ce qu'elle dit
alors madame Rudler arrive à des
conclusions contraire de ce de ses
confrères nancéen dans le cas de
Monsieur jacquesetel on retrouve du
phenob barbital mais pas de digoxine
alors pour monsieur lui c'est encore
mieux puisque madame Rudler vient dire
il n'y a aucun élément ni phenob
barbital qui aurait pu endormir ni
digxine qui aurait pu l'assassiner rien
la contreexertise de Michel Rudler c'est
une fabuleuse nouvelle pour votre
cliente c'est une fabuleuse nouvelle on
va demander au vu de cela la mise en
liberté et preuve si on a besoin que les
juges se sont d ah oui il y a un
problème dans cette affaire de triple
homicide
elle est mise en liberté elle est mise
en liberté parce qu'effectivement
l'expertise établie qu'il n'y a pas
[Applaudissements]
d'homicide
une libération qui passe mal chez les
polici nous fait drôle ça fait drôle
quand on a fait
l'enquête voit que sur une se une seule
analyse les choses peuvent changer comme
ça donc ça paralyse un petit peu
l'enquête il est
16and retrouve son fils et sa maison de
Max
professeur koudane on a du mal à
comprendre que cette nouvelle expertise
puisse avoir des résultats quasiment
opposés au vôrees est-ce que vous vous
êtes trompé alors à partir du moment où
on a un prélèvement on utilise la même
technique les résultats ça c'est
mathématique doivent être les mêmes que
ce soit dans les cheveux que ce soit
dans le foie puisque de toute manière le
produit toxique diffuse de façon Grosso
modo uniforme vous me dites qu'il y a eu
des différences de résultats je les
constate la seule explication
scientifique c'est que les méthodes ont
été
différentes alors qui
croire pour départager les experts le
juge demande une troème
expertise les résultats confirment
finalement le travail du professeur
koudane les deux hommes ont bel et bien
été
empoisonnés une déception pour Rodica
qui pendant ce temps n'est pas resté les
bras
[Musique]
croisés dès sa libération en avril 1993
elle attaque en justice tous ceux qui se
sont mis sur son
[Musique]
chemin famille des victimes policiers
médecin légiste directeur de la prison
tout le monde en prend pour son
matricule maître Michel elle y va pas un
peu fort votre cliente en attaquant tout
le monde comme ça à Tor et à travers
bien sûr qu'elle a tort et bien sûr que
ça se comprend imaginez que vous ayez
fait 10 mois de détention imaginez que
vous soyez traîné dans la boue dans la
presse tous les jours imaginez qu'on
vous accuse avoir tué votre premier mari
votre deuxè mari un vieux monsieur que
vous connaissiez dans ce cas-là mais
vous avez envie d'exploser je pense en
même temps qu'elle avait une lecture de
la société française qui était fausse
elle pensait qu'on était comme en
Roumanie elle pensait que les juges et
policiers recevaient des instructions
bref elle entretenait sa paranoïa comme
ça et ça explique beaucoup de son
comportement et elle est renvoyé devant
le tribunal correctionnel elle va être
condamnée d'ailleurs alors elle est
renvoyé devant le tribunal correctionnel
notamment pour avoir accusé le juge
d'instruction dans des conditions tout à
fait étonnantes comme elle est en
liberté elle se promène à NANC
tranquillement elle croise instruction
qui en voiture qui passe devant elle
alors qu'elle allait traverser elle se
couche par terre elle crie au secours au
secours la voiture vient de me renverser
elle va à la pharmacie en face en disant
le juge a voulu m'écraser et donc vous
imaginez le toet poursuivi pour
dénonciation imaginaire poursuivi pour
outrage elle passe devant le tribunal
correctionnel et c'est là où la justice
va la rattraper alors qu'on avait été
obligé de la mettre en liberté au moment
du rapport de Madame Rudler on l'envoie
détention ferme pour dénonciation
calomnieuse ferme ce qui va permettre de
la juger devant la Cour d'Assise détenu
et non pas libre ce qui aurait sans
doute tout changé si vous savez une dame
qui assise sur une chaise au premier
rang et quelqu'un qui est dans le boxe
entre deux gendarmes c'est pas
pareil vous avez attaqué les témoins les
policiers le juge d'inruction j'aié
j'aiété oui j'été accusé des j'ai accusé
des des fmations ils ont dit que j'avais
inventé que j'avais inventé tout ça
comment je peux inventer une telle
chose savoir le numéro d'immatriculation
de ton
juge c'était pas une invention c'était
mon
réalité est-ce que tout ça toutes ces
plaintes que vous avez fait tous ces
courriers que vous avez écrit est-ce que
tout ça ça ne vous a pas desservi bien
sûr qu' avit des servi mais moi je suis
pas quelqu'un qui se laisse marcher sur
les pieds qu qu Mar sur mes pied que
j'ai mal je pleure je réagis n'est-ce
pas je suis être
humain docteur bokel elle en fait
tellement qu'elle perd presque toute
crédibilité est-ce qu'elle en a
conscience elle développe en fait une
position qui est celle de d'argumenter
un vécu de préjudice elle estime que
elle est elle est mise en cause in
justustement qu'elle est incarcérée
injustement donc dans cette situation
dans ce vécu qu'elle développe de
victime et l'attaque à ce moment-là et
c'est aussi une façon d'exercer un
contrôle sur l'ensemble des des
personnes qui l'ont mise en cause qu'il
l' vis dans cette situation là est-ce
que vous vous pensez qu'elle est
pleinement responsable de ces actes elle
présente des traits de caractère très
particulierers mais en tout cas elle ne
présente pas de trouble psychiatrique
elle ne présente pas de troubl
psychopathologique effectivement on peut
considérer que elle est totalement
responsable de ses
actes Rodica negroyou n'est pas folle
elle peut donc être
jugée son procès s'ouvre en juin 1999 à
Nancy l'affaire Goldstein est trop
ancienne et s'est soldée par un nonlieu
elle comparaît donc pour
l'empoisonnement de Raymond jacel et et
de Gérard et
lui la famille attend que que rodigou
soit condamné si on a attendu 7 ans au
niveau de la procédure c'est que on a
accumulé suffisamment de preuves et
suffisamment d'éléments pour avoir une
décision pour qu'une décision soit enfin
prise la salle d'audience est comble
lorsque l'accusé fait son entrée dans le
box
Rodica négreyou à son procès elle arrive
très apprêtée
elle a sa chevelure blonde presque
platine impeccablement
ordonné elle a une petite veste de
tailleur à rayure et elle entre dans le
dans le box on sent déjà avec beaucoup
d'énergie on sent dès les premières
minutes que ça ne sera pas facile facile
maître Michel vous allez devoir composer
pendant ce procès avec la personalité de
votre cliente à chaque instant elle
intervient elle parle à T à travers
parle quand il faut pas on a beau lui
poser la main dessus pour qu'elle se
taise il y a rien à faire elle parle
quand même je veux dire quelque chose
Monsieur le Président et c'est parti
vous lui dites c'est pas comme ça qu'il
faut faire le problème c'est qu'elle ne
s'en rend pas compte et je vais même
plus loin je suis pas certain qu'elle
avait une confiance totale en ses avocat
parce que elle se sent tellement
persécuté victime d'accusation injuste
qu'elle pense que tout le monde est
contre elle elle perd son calme en
permanence qu'est-ce que vous redoutez
le plus moi ce que je redoute le plus
c'est qu'elle devienne antipathique vous
savez il y a rien de plus injuste qu'un
procès d'assise parce que vous pouvez
être le pire des salopards et paraître
sympathique la veuve de Maxeville ne
recule devant rien elle menace et
insulte les
témoins j'ai trouvé que le juge l'a
laissé faire tout ce qu'elle voulait
raconter tout ce qu' elle voulait il y
avait qu'elle qui avait la
parole mais au bout de 8 jours je dis
c'est pas possible qu'il la laisse
hurler comme ça dans le tribunal mais ce
tempérament explosif va se retourner
contre elle nous avons parfois titillé
ou provoquer je dirais Rodica pour que
finalement elle se lâche passez-moi
l'expression et c'est quand on se lâche
que souvent et bien on oublie
naturellement d'être prudent et on peut
amené à dire la vérité ce que on va
ensuite
regretter Rodica perd son calme
elle tombe dans le piège lorsque la cour
apprend enfin où sont passés les fameux
bonds du
trésor les 750000 Francs si attendus et
tellement voulus par rodigard sont entre
les mains d'une de leurs connaissance
qui n'est autre que Claude l'héritier de
Monsieur jacel maître Michel c'est àveu
c'est une chance pour vous ça aurait dû
être le tournant du procès on devrait se
dire bah finalement monsieur shael il
est peut-être mort de rien du tout et il
y avait autour de lui pas que Madame
negroyou mais une série de gens qui
étaient intéressés à ramasser tout ce
qui pouvait venir de la petite fortune
de Monsieur jactel et en fait elle va
transformer ça en quelque chose de
désastreux elle se met debout elle crit
C à voleur il m'a pris mon argent
c'est-à-dire en hurlant et donc ce n'est
plus ce monsieur qui a pris l'argent de
son oncle c'est madame ngroyou qui veut
absolument le butin il a pris mon argent
et ça donne un effet épouvantable tout
le monde oublie que le neveu avait menti
qu'il avait jamais dit ça qu'il a appris
cet argent il n'avait aucun droit à
l'époque pour le faire tout cela est
suspect elle va tout détruire par cette
attitude irresponsable finalement elle
est elle-même sa pire ennemie et il y
aura un autre moment d'ailleurs dans le
procès où elle va faire la même chose ah
mais exactement de la même façon on a
disposé sur une table devant la Cour
d'Assise tous les objets qu'on a trouvé
chez elle au moment de la perquisition
et qui appartenait manifestement
monsieur jacqutel on lui montre au fur
et à mesure une tour Effel un tableau de
la guerre de 14 contre toute évidence
elle dit c'est à moi c'est à moi c'est à
moi et cela agace tellement mon confrère
la parte civile que celui-ci prend sa
montre la pose sur la table des pièces à
conviction et dit ceci madame elle dit
c'est à moi c'est à moi il a PR dit non
madame c'est à moi il la remet rire
général c'est terminé pour les jurer est
une menteuse jusqu'à la fin mais en
réalité bien sûr que c'est une menteuse
là-dessus c'est une menteuse par
cupidité c'est de la
bêtise l'avocat général demande 20 ans
de
prison après seulement 3 heur de
délibérer le verdict tombe les jurés ont
suivi les
réquisitions coupable et condamné à 20
ans de réclusion
qu j'ai att je c
pas de
prison pour des choses que je n'ai
jamais
commis j'ai crié je suis innocente c'est
vous les criminels comme ça j'ai dit
c'est vous les criminels que vous
m'acusé innocente et voilà imaginez-vous
je m' suivu en prison c'était un
calvaire et ils ont jeté avec leur bout
sur ma personne propre ils m'ont S avec
mais je me je suis propre madame je suis
propre j'ai rien à me reprocher rien de
tout pour Rodica c'est un scandale pour
les familles un soulagement Jean etlouis
vous entendez coupable je l'ai pas
entendu longtemps puisquelle s'est mis à
crier elle s'est mis à crier insulter
toute la cour en particulier de traiter
le le juge d'assassin pour quelqu'un qui
est qui a eu un passé comme elle
sympathique donc quand j'ai entendu ça
j'ai bon enfin on est arrivé au bout je
me suis dit aussi comme je crois pas au
hasard 1 2 3 bon on arrête là il y
aurait peut-être eu 4 5 6 après à raison
d' un tous les 2
ans
bon use pas là mais je vous dis je crois
pas au
hasard aujourd'hui Rodica est libre
elle est revenue vivre à Maxeville où
elle continue à créer son
innocence toutes ces années de prison
comment vous les avez
vécu
je survécu resté 17 années innocent
parmi les parmi les personnes violentes
des vrais criminels des vrais des vraies
fautives
et respirer même air et avoir peur des
des des EU parce que en promenade ça je
quand même j'avais besoin respirer parce
que il y a un spéculation aussi de la
personnel de de la prison
d'administration pénitentiaire qui vois
une personne qui est en plus un peu qui
a un peu la tête plus haute que les
autres et ben il essaye il a pas la
domin l'écraser le fait que j'ai que
j'ai eu j'ai que je suis innocente et
combative et et voilà çaavait gêné vous
occupiez vos journées comment en prison
le momentl il a fallu travailler parce
que je travaillais vous savez je
travaillais et dans une cellule enfermé
je faisais des tailleur je faisais des
je sais la couture donc
allez tout fait ça dépêche-toi enferm
comme comme une bête et j'ai travaillé
quand même j'ai travaillé dans toutes
les prisons gratuitement c'était travail
forcé je faut dire que c'était travail
forcé je
travaillis quand elle est libérée en
janvier 2015 la sulfureuse blonde est
devenue une vieille dame elle a alors 75
ans le fait de à savoir libre qu'est-ce
que ça vous fait il y a une petite
crainte derrière quand même déjà ça
donne des frissons quand on quand on
apprend ça et une petite crainte dit
qu'est-ce qu'elle va faire puis que
avant quand elle est déjà quand elle
avait déjà des poiliers liés c'était des
plaintes contre tout le monde
aujourd'hui comment
allez-vous ben aujourd'hui je suis
celuivante de quoi vivez-vous ben
aujourd'hui j'ai vu j'ai une petite
retraite retraite malheureuse bon et
j'ai fait également une petite j'ai fait
le jardinage àoir une potager
et voilà pour pouvoir exister manger des
choses qui sont naturelles qui qu'il
m'aident aussi financièrement
c'est-à-dire pour moi-même bien sûr
jardinage est pour moi-même et pour mon
fils vous cultivez des légumes voilà je
cul des légumes voilà c'est les fleur
qui sont voilà c'est
euh j'ai fait des choses regarder mes
mains et ben ça se voit que j'ai il a
beaucoup travaillé mes mains et ma tête
ils ont travaillé honnêtement pour les
autres et pas pour moi parce que
maintenant j'ai plus
rien Rodica n'a plus un S depuis
quelques années elle a subi plusieurs
déconvenus la famille élu a décidé de
réoster à son tour elle a attaqué Rodica
ngroyou en
justice c'est c'était dû au fait que
elle a eu beaucoup plus d'avantage que
ce qu'elle méritait c'està dire au
niveau de l'héritage elle a eu un peu
plus que la part des enfants il y a eu
aussi la pension de reversion que elle
n'y a absolument pas droit quelle
continuer de toucher à l'époque oui
ouais et donc qu'est-ce que ça a donné
ces poursuites vous avez pu ben on a
récupéré l'argent touché en trop par
elle voilà ça s'est arrêté là
et depuis on a pu du tout de contact
c'est important pour vous oui ça
remettait des choses à leur place ou
c'est surtout ça c'était plus symbolique
que qu'une histoire
[Musique]
d'argent ultime humiliation pour elle la
justice a considéré que son union avec
Gérard et lui était un mariage blanc sa
nationalité française lui a donc été
retirée
rek gryou cette déchéance de nationalité
vous qui teniez tellement àeniè
française qu'est-ce que ça vous a fait
j'étais très triste j'étais malheureuse
parce que je sais que je l'avais mérité
et que je la mérite c'était un vol mais
l'avait volé parce que c'était la mienne
je l'avais obtenue par mérite par le
travail honnête
par j'ai rien fait du mal rien de tout
pour être euh voler devant la
nationalité
française pour faire face à l'adversité
Rodica a toujours pu compter sur un
homme son
fils son fils va passer sa vie il va la
consacrer entièrement à reprendre le
dossier de sa mère à étudier feuille par
feuille pour essayer de trouver la
moindre faille capable de faire tomber
la condamnation de Rodica
negroyou une ténacité qui finit par
payer après des mois de travail
minutieux le fils de de Rodica fait une
découverte qui va relancer
l'affaire il s'aperçoit que dans
l'expertise médicale on a ditque que
Monsieur jacqu tellel prenait du
colchimax et dans le colchimax dans la
composition de ce médicament on retrouve
du
phenobarbital le phénob barbital c'est
cette molécule qui a été retrouvée dans
le corps de Raymond jactel celle qui
aurait contribué à l'empoisonner selon
les experts mais si le retraité prenait
un médicament qui en contenait alors ça
change
tout professeur cette découverte c'est
un revers pour vous à partir du moment
où dans le rapport d'expertise j'ai
écrit qu'il n'y avait pas eu de
prescription thérapeutique il faut
reconnaître que c'est une erreur voilà
et finalement cette discussion sur les
expertises ça jette le trouble ah ben je
veux dire et euh donc Madame ngroyou et
bien sûr ses conseils peuvent se jeter
effectivement sur ce détail de
l'histoire médico-légale qui à mon avis
n'est pas très très importante si on
analyse les faites sur le plan
toxicologique de façon mathématique mais
néanmoins je veux dire que ça me paraît
tout à fait
normal sur la base de ce nouvel élément
Rodica negroyou saisite en octobre 2007
la Commission de révision des
condamnations
pénales
[Musique]
maître vous êtes l'avocat de Rodica
ngroyou vous déposez une demande de
révision sur quel fondement alors en
matière d'empoisonnement il faut bien
dire quel est le produit qui a servi à
l'empoisonnement or on nous on nous a
servi pendant des années vous l'avez
empoisonné au phobarbital mais le
phenobarbital ça faisait partie des
médicaments habituels de Monsieur
Jacques tellel c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons fait cette requête
devant la commission de révision de la
Cour de cassation parce que ça c'est
c'est un élément nouveau de nature à
faire naître un doute bien sûr c'est un
élément nouveau commission de révision
de la Cour de cassation interroge des
experts les experts vont vont
effectivement déclarer qu'il y a eu une
erreur d'appréciation et que ce
médicament contenait bien du phenob
barbital mais ils vont considérer que la
dose de phenob barbital qui a été
relevée dans le corps de de Monsieur
Jacques Tell est une dose non pas
thérapeutique c'estd c'est pas une dose
qui correspond
à des médicaments mais une dose toxique
ce qui signifierait que on aurait pe
rajouter plusieurs euh plusieurs dose de
phénob barbital pour attenter à sa
vie la demande est rejetée en avril 2010
une nouvelle déception pour Rodica qui
refuse pourtant de renoncer un an plus
tard elle dépose une nouvelle demande en
révision de récentes études viennent
apporter un éclairage inattendu la
présence de digoxine dans le corps des
deux victimes pourrait s'expliquer
autrement que par un
empoisonnement que disent ces nouvelles
études anglosaxon il s'avère que des
études effectuées par des anglosaxons
qui ont suivi une population d'obèse
pendant plusieurs années ont permis de
s'interroger sur les traces de digoxine
qu'on trouve dans les analyses
biologiques parce que ces obèses qui ne
prenaient pas de digoxine ils avaient
des traces de digoxine dans leurs
analyses biologiques ce qui a permis à à
ces médecins de poursuivre leurs
investigations et de constater que
certains
individus plus particulièrement ceux qui
étaient atteints de pathologies genre
diabète ou
hypertension fabriqué de manière
endogène de de la digoxine et bingo il
se trouve que une des victimes souffrait
de diabète et l'autre souffrait
d'hypertension c'est-à-dire qu'il
rentrait dans le champ d'application des
études qu'on vient de onbient de citer
donc ces morts pourrai être des morts
naturells ces morts sont des morts
naturels tout est possible mais ça me
paraît tellement extraordinaire là pour
moi on est plutôt on va dire au niveau
du roman de
l'utopie plus que de la démonstration
scientifique donc si on l' retrouvé dans
des proportions pareiles dans leur corps
il a fallu aider un peu la nature ah oui
ça c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire des avis scientifiques une fois de
plus complètement opposé et une première
véritable victoire pour Rodica faer
rarissime la commission de révision
ordonne de nouveau un supplément
d'information les arguments de Rodica
ont visiblement fait mouche des
investigations sont en cours pour la
famille et lui ses recours à répétition
sont de plus en plus difficiles à
supporter pour nous effectivement c'est
puuisant mais c'est une façon aussi de
faire parler d'elle je trouve ça pénible
et euh bon mais elle a le droit de
faire la loi française le lui permet
vous renoncerez un jour jamais je
continuerai jusqu'à la fin de ma vie
euh défendre ma mon innocence et ma
liberté ils m'ont volé la vie 17 années
des vol mais j'espère que j'aurai une
révision j'espère que j'aurai une
révision je suis l'innocente de
Maxeville madame je suis l'innocente de
Maxeville je suis pas l'imposonneuse de
Maxeville et je crois que qu' un jour
viendra et que tout sera vu à la lumière
et que je serai in
santé